a few years ago elon musk proposed his
vision of making our highway systems
3d by constructing an underground
network of tunnels built for super-fast
point-to-point travel
however since then we haven't heard too
much from the media
or the company themselves about the
progress so far
so what happened to the boring company
[Music]
well starting off we actually have seen
some progress in las vegas over the past
year
in may of 2020 the boring company
finished excavating their second tunnel
underneath the las vegas convention
center
this tunnel is part of the people mover
project which
is intended to transport visitors from
one side of the convention center
to the other before this the first
tunnel underneath the convention center
was actually completed a few months
before
in february of 2020 since then the
boring company has been working on
constructing
entry and exit stations on both sides of
the tunnel
just a few days ago we got an update
from the boring company
in the form of video that showcased the
inside of one of these stations
though there is clearly still some work
to be done it does seem like they will
meet their projected deadline of january
originally this deadline was put in
place to have the tunnels operational by
ces 2021
but an in-person ces 2021 has since been
cancelled
so at this point there's really no rush
however completing these stations will
only finish the first phase of the
convention center project
the entire project is worth 52.5 million
but we don't yet know exactly the full
details of the project
so we'll just have to wait and see what
they construct with the remaining cash
aside from this the boring company has
also been able to win over a significant
amount of interest from
other las vegas companies in june wind
resorts reveal
that they're working with the boring
company on a potential tunnel between
their resort and the encore
in the las vegas convention center these
two hotel slash casinos
are massive wind resorts has 2 700 rooms
and 110 000 square feet of casino space
similarly the encore has another 2 000
rooms along with a couple of restaurants
so once las vegas gets back up and
running
there will be no shortage of people
interested in using the proposed tunnel
and it's not just these two either
resorts world las vegas
a malaysian-owned multi-billion dollar
hotel casino
is also hoping to work with the boring
company on a similar project
resorts world las vegas received
approval from clark county
a little while back in august but till
very recently
wind resorts was still waiting on
approval they did however receive
approval
on december 1st taking a look at the
proposed tunnel layout
the first thing you realize is that
resort's world is
already super close to the convention
center it's literally
across the street as a result ironically
the tunnel will actually cover more
distance than if you were to simply walk
nonetheless the tunnels aren't that long
the tunnel proposed by wind resorts
comes in at 0.6 miles
while the tunnel proposed by resorts
world las vegas comes in at 0.4 miles
so only one mile of tunnel total
with that being said their proposed
tunnels in las vegas
are no doubt for novelty purposes the
two hotels
are likely planning on using the tunnels
as a means to get more people to book at
their hotels
as opposed to actually providing a super
practical mode of transportation
on the topic of tunnel length the super
short length of the tunnels will
significantly restrict the max speed
that vehicles within a tunnel
can reach as a result elon musk's
proposed 100 miles per hour plus speeds
will not come to fruition
here considering that each tunnel is
only about a half a mile in length
we'll likely only see max speeds of
about 60 miles per hour
if that something else to note is that
catching a ride on one of these hotel
sponsored tunnels
will not be free the ceo of las vegas
convention
and visitors authority steve hill
suggests that each ride will cost
approximately three to five dollars
the tunnels that were funded by the las
vegas convention center however
will be free as they were funded by
taxpayer dollars
considering the wealth of the people who
generally visit las vegas
and stay at these hotels however they
likely won't mind a three to five dollar
fee
just to try it out but these individuals
are also likely to have high
expectations
as well so i'm sure we'll hear about any
potential issues with the tunnel
very quickly anyways moving forward
elon musk and the boring company have
suggested some more substantial plans
for the las vegas area
they're looking to build out the
convention center loop into downtown las
vegas with about 20 to 30 stops within
the heart of the city
as well as the las vegas airport aside
from this
looking even further into the future
they're wanting to eventually add an
extension to the las vegas boring system
that connects it to la these longer
tunnels
are much closer to elon's vision and
would actually make more practical sense
however there doesn't seem to be much
official progress on any of these plans
so that's the state of the boring
company today
they've been making some progress on
building some novelty tunnels mostly in
las vegas
but what about outside of las vegas as
some projects have been shaping out
elsewhere
as well though they're not as far along
in the process
one such project is the chicago express
loop
the chicago infrastructure trust or the
cit
have actually been working with the
boring company to make transportation
between the center of the city
and the airport much faster currently
the plan entails building a main tunnel
between block 37 in downtown chicago
and chicago's o'hare airport this main
tunnel branches off as it approaches the
airport
in order to provide specific access to
each of the three terminals
unlike the las vegas convention center
tunnel the chicago express loop will be
privately funded by the boring company
consequently
following the construction the boring
company will actually be given the
responsibility
of operating and maintaining the system
as well
to recoup their costs the company is
charging fares
but they promise that it'll only be half
the price of regular taxi
slash rideshare services if they are
able to reach this price target
the chicago express loop will likely be
quite an attractive option for
individuals
traveling to and from chicago as
the longer format of this tunnel is
expected to allow for full speeds of up
to 150 miles per hour
similarly the boring company is also
looking at a project in la
as well called the dugout loop the
dugout loop is supposed to provide
transportation between either the los
feliz
east hollywood or ram park village
neighborhood to the dodgeo stadium
this tunnel will also be 100 privately
funded by the boring company
and fares are expected to cost just one
dollar each
considering that this tunnel will often
be used heavily to get to the stadium
the boring company is also offering an
option to reserve tickets for the loop
ahead of time
currently the tunnel is only expected to
transport fourteen hundred people per
event
or about two and a half percent of the
cdm's capacity
however if things prove to run smoothly
it's expected that the city will allow
for up to 2800 people to use the system
each event throughout the various events
and games every year
the total annual passenger count is
expected to be a solid 250
000 or nearly five stadiums full anyways
those are the mid-level tunnel builds
that the boring company is currently
engaged in
as for large-scale projects we do have
one major tunnel that is currently
in the consideration phase which is the
washington dc to baltimore loop
this loop would span about 35 miles so
still not a super long project in the
hundreds of miles
but it is much longer than their other
projects thus far
despite this similar to the last couple
of projects this route will also be 100
privately funded by the boring company
but i don't think that would be a big
problem for elon musk
currently the plan is to not have any
branches in the tunnel and
for the tunnel to run straight between
the two cities
however the boring company claims that
they can add branches
at any time in the future with that
being said
the estimated transportation time
between the cities using the loop
is only 15 minutes the same trip by car
would take you 43 minutes according to
google maps
on top of this the boring company is
also considering making this
into a hyperloop capable of speeds up to
600 miles per hour
now since this is a relatively small
distance the time savings between the
regular loop and hyperloop isn't too
drastic
but it does nonetheless cut down the
travel time to just 8 minutes
this will surely be useful to people who
make this commute every day
for work and finally looking into the
future of the boring company
it's likely that they will simply work
on similar small to medium-like projects
for the next couple of years
this is a passion project for elon musk
so it's unlikely to receive the same
attention
as spacex and tesla despite this
we may see the boring company dub into
some larger projects in the hundreds of
miles
by the end of this decade however an
underground highway system
like the visualizations we have seen so
far is likely decades away
if they do decide to continue pursuing
that vision
it may make more sense to simply provide
underground solutions for popular routes
rather than building entire underground
highway systems
but that's just what i think what do you
guys think about the future of the
boring company
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys support creating better
public transportation networks
in the us and of course consider joining
our discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you